Tenemos la ecuación -16 = x/4 + 2, y necesitamos
resolver para x. Entonces realmente sólo
necesitamos aislar la variable x en un lado de
esta ecuación, y la mejor manera de hacerlo es
primero aislar el término completo x / 4 de todos
los demás términos. Para hacer eso eliminemos este
2, y la mejor manera de deshacerse de este
2 es restarlo, pero si queremos restarlo del
lado derecho también tenemos que restarlo del
lado izquierdo, porque esta es una ecuación,
si esto es igual a eso cualquier cosa que
hagamos de este lado también tenemos que
hacerla de este otro lado. Entonces restamos
2 de ambos lados: restamos 2 de la derecha,
restamos 2 de la izquierda y en el lado izquierdo
nos queda -16 - 2 = -18, y esto es igual a x / 4,
y luego tenemos 2 positivo - 2 que va a ser 0,
por lo que ni siquiera tenemos que escribirlo.
Podría escribir un más 0, pero creo que es
innecesario, entonces tenemos -18 = x /4.
Y nuestro objetivo es aislar la x para resolverla,
y la mejor manera de hacer eso es si tenemos x / 4
aquí y lo multiplicamos por 4 nos quedará la
x, entonces podemos multiplicar esto por 4.
Pero recuerda que esta es una ecuación y todo lo
que hagas en el lado derecho tienes que hacerlo en
el lado izquierdo y viceversa. Entonces, si
multiplicamos el lado derecho por 4 también
tenemos que multiplicar el lado izquierdo por
4, obtenemos que 4 • 18 negativo = x / 4 • 4,
x / 4 • 4 cancela los cuatros, porque divides
algo entre 4 y lo multiplicas por 4, por lo que
sólo nos quedará una x. Y del otro lado 4 • 18
negativo, veamos, vamos a escribirlo: 18 • 4,
8 • 4 es 32, 4 • 1 es 4 + 3 es 7, 72, pero esto
es 18 negativo por 4, entonces es 72 negativo,
x = 72 negativo o -72. Y si queremos verificarlo
podemos sustituirlo en nuestra ecuación original,
así que hagámoslo, sustituyamos esto en la
ecuación original. La ecuación original es
-16 es igual a, y en lugar de escribir x voy a
escribir -72, es igual a -72 / 4 + 2. Veamos si
esto es cierto: el lado derecho se simplifica como
-72 / 4, ya sabemos que eso es -18, entonces esto
es igual a -18 + 2, así queda la ecuación, y luego
el lado derecho, 18 negativo + 2 es 16 negativo,
entonces todo se cumple: este lado derecho,
cuando x = -72, en efecto es igual a -16.